welcome to this video playing m7 b5 m7
b5 this is some kind of secret agency or
something I don't know okay we got a
queen's gambit you always play Bishop a
form even back in the day when that
wasn't the main line okay so a six hmm
yeah there are moves them I have to add
this move before I don't know it's just
good hmm he has some maybe some
additional possibilities there for a
knight c6 pacesetter I don't know
huh okay let's see what is doing with a
six black intended to take them on c4
and then play be five yes okay why do I
go to e5 ok I'm going back there he
takes I have the edge file at least
let's see okay so he will take them
later probably after I castle but ok I
really cannot delay castle forever ok
always playing this immediately but I
can take d5 right I was thinking it's a
bit early yeah I think he needed to
spend at least one or two moves on
preparing that um this is a PS we se4 at
the end huh funny funny
former things too well it's a pawn the
simplest form of chess winning upon
somewhere and try to win in the end game
yeah I don't think he should trade
Quincy no let's see here how do i play
here rookie one looks okay using this
file yeah here was thinking yeah look
the aids coming to I would go before
here I don't know
and maybe we should be three but ok it's
dumb I still probably have to do
something about this pawn some point and
I have ideas like 94 and 95 now so I
don't don't think that Bishop d5 is a
big issue and maybe I have a look
default check ok just straight stuff I
don't check that very much I'm just
going back to this great central square
e for what ok I'm getting this Bishop
I think I came back requested take back
really hmm okay all I don't don't do
that normally because it was clearly a
blunder not a mouse slip take less
accepted but i'd like to take back
except i like to try to see how are you
windows end game you know this is an
interesting are still an interesting
thing to to check the technical side of
this let's see how do i play here maybe
what do i do f3e for ya first to get the
king king into the game okay stop that
now i think i'm going over probably to
them to the Queen side yeah mostly I
mostly accepted the take back for
instructional purposes when you're
screwing up the pronunciation trying to
see how this is a win I wonder ever
should go g4 in this position take sandy
for two might be an interesting concrete
solution to it
now this is actually not that easy it's
not that easy to win this let us think
about it I can take the night over to
see three and then play for e for later
he also has a check and coming to f1
this is cubed awkward
I'm not completely sure how to win this
the idea is to go to see three and then
try to get fon okay it's f4 here f4 back
to e6 I wonder that is the right way to
go g4 takes f4 check king is 64 should
move King g3 h5 King edge for my it
looks quite strong
it's a bit tricky with one minute on the
clock check
or maybe time warning let's start with
this and actually it's probably no big
difference but this was my idea trying
to get to g5
not sure how I went after king of six
now I have G I can just go g3 or
something and go from there but I don't
know how I win actually night to e3 and
e5 check maybe that could be the way not
sure what he's thinking about I don't
think he can allow King g5 that that
that looks impossible to stand
hmm the problem is that ok night to d4
was also good then he fine but I don't
see how I get this in he has Bishop c2
but i was so going to try Bishop see to
us right now might even if I get in 1945
it's great but he has Bishop c2 i can i
can give check if I check kick fr 94
with a fork that's that's the winner
yeah just just just just everything fits
together if I've checking FF 94 forking
so that is why it's not moving and I'm
threatening 94 95 and it sets winning if
i get to g5 black is falling apart there
it was an interesting technical tasks
this is why I accepted accepted the tape
back I didn't play it well technically
i'm pretty sure about that I think I
could have played it better
we will see afterwards hmm well I was
saying that like it's not able to hold
this but how do I win actually I don't
see it at the moment you six is not
winning f5 is not willing I don't see a
win at the moon that's awkward
okay and he has aged for coming black
forfeits on time Jim should probably i'm
winning at the end but yeah i can i can
move the King up who that wasn't a good
technical display I really should have
won that much easier and I think
actually the problem is i'm starting
with the wrong move here i'm starting
with the wrong move I played here and he
went f5 okay maybe that's okay but i
think this is just better this is better
and preventing f5 and I keep this option
of f3 Andy for open this is a much
better way to play I get the king then
up and I have a very sound pawn
structure after this f5 it gets a bit
tricky and this is a pleat here right
yeah this is an interesting alternative
that I saw but I wasn't sure about how
good this is this kind of thing I didn't
want to damage my structure like that
but I have a passer it was an
alternative okay but I think I don't
think it was that bad what I did that is
interesting of course check but maybe
it's not enough to win it's it's
possible the question is do I have a win
here 92 Bishop there and then check he
went back 90 form yeah all is the same
thing I didn't see a win here I really
didn't f5 f5 wins
I can go at five you know what I did not
really appreciate that after this of
course I can take here and then go back
and then take now that wins that
probably will win yeah I didn't see that
I mean I saw that check this is a poops
um cheeks that this is winning of course
but I didn't see that that the other one
is also i'm not sure about this one
anymore I still at five probably but I
didn't see a five and here it got it got
really really really messy Teague's here
night b7 is strong yeah but here by now
I was irritated I really was it's funny
that the computer still says I'm
completely winning I'm surprised that
this is the case not after that anymore
a5 was still winning yeah the troop ones
I think I kind of strong okay and again
again I'm winning i was i was thinking
that somewhere around here there might
be something for black but i'm even
winning in there in the end it's it's
funny not easy at all the same game yeah
i think check I kept check up the nice
position mostly gia teague 0 you can
yeah you can also take with the pawn I
mean this is not totally idiotic like
doing this and putting the night like
here but taking with the night is good
it's a great centralized piece I think I
really can improve here with g-form I
mean I this is the normal that you play
to prevent h5 and f5 but I kind of
forgot about it after I went when
they're free and then it hit me
I was thinking f34 but I didn't really
think about that he has f5 okay well
thanks for watching